and tensions remain high in the holy
land this morning where right-wing
Israeli leaders led a March in the West
Bank and Palestinians say Israeli
soldiers killed a 15 year old teenage
boy yesterday the faithful held prayers
to celebrate holidays for the Region's
three major religions a few days after a
major outbreak of violence there MTS
tayab is in Jerusalem
as Christian pilgrims filled the Church
of the Holy Sepulcher where it's
believed Jesus was buried and
resurrected to Mark Easter Sunday
Jewish worshipers gathered at the
Western Wall the holiest place for Jews
to Mark Passover
and at the Al-Aqsa mosque the third most
important site in Islam Palestinian
Muslims performed Ramadan prayers and a
rare convergence of celebrations in the
three different faiths
it's only every 30 years or so that
Easter Passover and Ramadan occur all at
once a reminder of the religious
connections and divisions that have
defined Jerusalem for thousands of years
and the narrow Alleyways of Jerusalem's
Old City those divisions were on full
display as the soaring tension spread
far beyond these ancient walls
engines that were triggered by raids on
the Al-Aqsa Moss last week when Israeli
forces beat Palestinians barricaded
inside with batons and the butt of
rifles
sparking Fury and Rocket fire from armed
Palestinian groups in Gaza Lebanon and
Syria
Israel responded by carrying out air
strikes in each of those places while
separate Palestinian attacks in Tel Aviv
and the West Bank killed three people
with growing fears the violence could
spiral out of control devotees of all
three faiths were United in praying for
peace precipious Mornings in fiestaib at
the old city in Jerusalem